[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à 50 words
vancouver en colombie britannique
je vous accueille ici dans notre
exposition temporaire qui est arrivé fin
janvier qui va rester ici pour quatre
mois c'est à dire jusqu'au 22 avril 2018
donc cette exposition s'appelle la
science de wiplie croyez le ou non
donc c'est à partir des collections de
voir bientôt hippie mais ça a été
développée et créé par à la fois oui pis
entertainment et 6 nov
a contrario donc cette exposition nous
avait proposé par seven foot ici vous
allez pouvoir être étonnés émerveillés
votre curiosité va être piqués par tout
ce que vous allez voir ici des objets
des animaux des faits scientifiques des
histoires facilement de fabuleuses
incroyable mais la science pourra
toujours nous expliquer ce qu'il ya
derrière
vous allez également vous sentir tout
petit parfois par rapport à ce géant aux
ambertois holder devant nous avons une
représentation ici à vous allez
également pouvoir toucher des choses je
vous emmène vers la partie météorite de
l'exposition où vous pourrez toucher une
des météorites
c'est une exposition pour petits et
grands nous les conseillons pour les
familles les groupes scolaires tout âge
peuvent s'y retrouver
évidemment à partir de 8 ans et plus
intéressant de commencer à s'intéresser
encore plus à la science derrière toutes
ces histoires et ces objets mais les
petits pourront très bien s'amuser ici
il ya beaucoup de d'espacés où vous
pouvez voir
et vous amuser toucher des choses
[Musique]